ukrainian army medics carry a wounded
soldier into a field hospital close to
the front line
a piece of shrapnel has ripped through
his side
the wound looks small but the sharp
metal fragment inside will kill him if
not dealt with fast
the medics pump the soldier with
anesthetic and pure oxygen
they pack the wound
he will be evacuated to a hospital
further back from the front line to have
the shrapnel removed
the teams say some nights they have to
treat up to 70 men wounded as they
defend their positions against the
russian army advance in a town close by
many of the medics have worked in
foreign war zones for decades but they
never expected one day they would be
saving lives at home
my whole professional life i've been
treating people i love people i love
life in all ways i chose my field
because death is the worst enemy
russians worst deed is that it turned me
a defender of life
into a killer
i have had to shoot in this war and most
likely i hit the target
some medics sleep in rooms next to the
makeshift trauma treatment area before
their shift starts
the shelves are full of medicine vital
for saving lives but
it's not medicine we need one of the
surgeons told me
it's weapons
more soldiers arrive
nurses prepare rehydration fluid others
search for veins in the men's arms so
they can fit cannulas and administer
medicine fast
the men are exhausted and dazed
we are tired and shell-shocked says this
soldier but it's to be expected of war
what's known
the most common injuries are from
shrapnel gunshot wounds blown off limbs
brain trauma and shell shock
we treat shell shock with simple
symptomatic medicines
there's not much else we can do
another soldier is brought in with a gun
shop wound under his arm the medics
calmly clean the area 55 year old lubima
seems relaxed but the bullet was only
millimeters away from potentially ending
his
life luberman took a gunshot wound
yesterday afternoon
the medics here say he is incredibly
lucky that that bullet did not sever the
archery in his arm
he will now go from here be taken from
here by ambulance
to one of the local hospitals further
back from the front line for further
treatment
some of the volunteers don't want to be
identified because they say russian
forces are targeting medics treating
ukrainian soldiers
after being treated lubimir eats
breakfast while waiting to be evacuated
before the war he was a construction
worker renovating the chernobyl nuclear
plant
their mortar guys can get really close
to us and they're difficult to see and
shoot they approach our trenches and
throw grenades before lunch yesterday
there were 50 shells that hit near our
position
russian artillery shells and mortars
target ukrainian positions in fields
close by
no one knows how many wounded will be
brought to the field hospital
in the hours ahead
charles stratford al jazeera eastern
ukraine